welcome to Rocky - you may not know
we're actually on apply University
science outreach for them we have a
school Eliska program in here that we
offer for the K to 12 community
alongside teachers and education
educators and scientists alike we have
how many of you guys have been here for
love experiences it's like a full circle
how many y'all have been involved in any
of our research programs so our lab
jump-started RS SRP okay couple ends to
the K to 12th community and for teachers
so we're always encouraging science and
encouraging people becoming involved in
the scientific process and understanding
what that's like and promoting equitable
access to all of them and myself I
forgot to introduce myself the last time
some hotels fall and marcheeta scientist
educator and send in fun carrots are a
couple of my team members we have Jeanie
our director it's in our program manager
our communications coordinator inators
me in the back and who's our
administrators still checking in awesome
kids that's coming in tonight
and so before I introduce the speaker I
just want everyone to open your bag of
chips right now so that we don't have
Franklin later in the top
I want to make sure that everyone is
paying attention getting some great
advice from our speaker today just to be
sure to hold our conversation still
after this talk I will with hammer
question and answer segment wait can ask
anything about the slide by our speaker
you know reasonable questions and so
I'll introduce our speaker so today we
have Katie Davis she's a clinical
psychologist and today should be
presenting her research that she did in
a fellowship at Johns Hopkins and so on
how can it be so sorry her research is
at Columbia she has a private practice
here at MIT she also lives in New York
City and one fun fact about PE is that
she's never tried ketchup
talk to her about that
the minute we have plenty of seats in
front they're like 10 seats Twitter and
those who are sitting in the other seat
if you guys can move down so that those
coming in can fill in to the sides yeah
that'd be great
all right so join me and welcome in
[Applause]
everybody thank you so much for having
me today I'm really excited to tell you
about my work
[Music]
so just to give you an overview of what
we're gonna talk about today first I'm
gonna tell you a bit about myself and my
career and how I got here then I'm gonna
give you some background information
that you need to know to really
understand the research that will
eventually tell you about first I'm
going to give you an introduction to
statistics and we'll talk about a couple
of the models that I used in my study
then I'll give you some background
information and about fMRI research in
general and some different modalities
that summarize research that are coming
to you
and that'll give you some background
about just basic neural anatomy and I'll
teach you a little bit about the brain
structure that I'll be talking about
that make up an emotion regulation
circuit in your brain and then I'll
finally get to my research and I'll tell
you a bit about my study on the
relationship between learning and
reading and anxiety and then I'll talk
about the implications of my research
and what does this mean for you and what
can you do to reduce anxiety and to
improve their learning psychology before
he began the Black Star he took a minute
to make sure everybody was okay
so it's been a long week we're almost at
the end of the school year so the
particularly stressful time for
everybody let's just take a second to be
at the beach
chica mentally thng took a deep breath
now we can move on so just to tell you a
bit about myself and how I got here in
case anybody is interested in
neuroscience or psychology and wants to
maybe pursue a career similar to mine I
grew up in New Jersey
I was a public high school and I was
immediately interested in science like
beginning and then crave especially
chemistry and civic I was really into
science olympiad and like all the really
super dirty paths which i think is great
and I also had tutoring jobs as I think
fuller and I became really interested in
how people learn I really wondered why
do some people learn better than other
people why do some people study better
than other people and why do some people
just like school and other people don't
so I went to college I went to brown and
I was an education major and I studied
mostly human development and
neuroscience psychology intro - I
started to develop like some knowledge
of learning system and especially as
they intersect with special education
and education policy and I had a bunch
of summer jobs I was really interested
at the time and learning disabilities so
I had some summer jobs at the NYU Child
Study Center and there's a school on the
Upper West Side called West Indies for
the wonderful school and I worked with
kids that had some learning difficulties
not inspired me to go to graduate school
for fun
cytology eventually I thought it would
be originally I thought I would be a
full psychologist so I went to you a
combined school and in clinical program
that usually the University in the Bronx
and there was exposed to neuro
psychology which is the relationship
between brain functioning and behavior
so he was really interested in the
intersection between neuro psychology
and education and learning and I was
first exposed to research so that I
pursued a postdoc fellowship at Columbia
which is where he did the study that
I'll talk about today um I did my
fellowship with something called the
promise program which is a wonderful
program that supports kids with reading
disorders so I did a lot of neural
imaging on learning disorders I did
reading disorder and related
disabilities today I couldn't split my
time could you put it will work right
around here actually and I see kids
learning and attention disorders that we
work on strategies to improve learning
and I do research at Johns Hopkins they
have a lab in Midtown and I study
interventions about all of that leader
um so before we begin I want to give you
some background knowledge that you'll
really need to have and actually before
I do that the first thing I'm going to
teach is an introduction to some
statistical models that are relevant for
today but in general I just want to
digress for a moment and give a little
sohbat speech about how I think you all
should Jesus intersects if given the
opportunity in high school um actually
think statistics is one of the most
important things for people to know
science has been on signs of the like
I found that since I have learned about
statistics among much more important
consumer of not only just research but
journalism and other information
and that I'm exposed to I have a lot of
kids that are really anxious about the
SATs I don't know if any of you are kind
of there yet um the standardized test
scores and how this score is translate
to percentiles and what are the odds be
given the better score the next time
around whether there's four actually
mean relative to the rest of the
population this is all information that
if you knew statistic would really
deepen your understanding of even
information so like relevant to life
exact so did you get the chance for sure
study specific so anyway today I'll give
you a brief overview of two months the
first is called correlation and you
probably use correlation before support
lesions just discusses the Association
or the relationship between two
variables as one variable moves the
other variable moves so so we call them
the independent variable in the
dependent variable I'm just assuming
that most of you know that independent
variable F fact that you kind of
variable Y effect so independent
variable is the one that typically we've
manipulated studies so as we manipulate
the independent variable and it changes
we see the dependent variable change as
well
sometimes as the independent variable
increases the dependent variable also
increases
sometimes as one increases the other
decreases however the important things
that you should know about correlation
is it doesn't mean causation a change in
the independent variable does not
necessarily cause a change in the
dependent variable and a really good
example that I like to use to explain
the difference between correlation and
causation is plotted on my slide so I
don't know if you know this but the
number of ice-cream sales is directly
correlated with the number of drownings
in a given year and it's specific time
this year
so as ice-cream scale is Cola so do the
number of drowning
it's not because when you need a lot of
ice cream you got sad and you can't swim
there's something called a confounding
variable is another variable just kind
of floating around the inflation in this
case is that they both happen in
summertime so experience sounds go up in
the summer drownings go up in the summer
we see the two variables moving together
but one does not cause the other so is
everybody understanding the difference
okay great I feel great as I'm
explaining something and you guys are
totally lost feel free to just shoot up
a hand and let me know I'm happy to slow
down and take questions as I'm talking
umm so correlation does not imply
causation but sometimes it is really
helpful to come up with a statistical
model that can better show causation to
kind of prove a conclusion in a study
the one that is actually the only one
[Music]
it's called mediation so mediation is a
statistical model that involves three
variables so we have the independent
variable the dependent variable which we
discussed earlier and then a third
variable called the mediator and the
mediator explains the relationship
between the two other variables so for
the person that's example I want to just
discuss the relationship between grades
and Happiness so we can see an
association between between grades and
happiness as your grades go up your
happiness probably those up as well so
there's a correlation however you can't
necessarily say that an increase in your
brain directly causes an increase in
your happiness instead one might suppose
that self-esteem is also in the mix here
so we can test as your grades go up
their self-esteem goes up and then your
happiness increases so self-esteem me
believe for relationships between grades
and happiness
so how do we know that we need to first
be the initial relationship between
grades of happiness we need to see that
correlation there we need to see a
relationship between grades and
self-esteem and we need to see a
relationship between self-esteem and
Happiness and then when we jump all
three variables in the mathematical
model we can see that the relationship
between grades and self-esteem is
preserved as if the relationship between
self-esteem and happiness but this
initial relationship the initial
correlation might actually go away
either partially or completely when we
count accounts or self-esteem changes um
if we have all of those conditions
satisfied and if we see changes in these
variables happening at a temporal
sequence in time order then we can say
that we have immediate mediation model
and we can say that there probably are
causal relationships going on here so
grades cause cause the increase in
self-esteem self-esteem cause the
increase in happiness so that's gonna
conclude my thirty seconds now that you
learned a bit about stats I want to talk
a bit about just generals fMRI research
I'm assuming most of you are familiar
with MRIs in general some of you may
actually have had them um for those of
you who are less familiar MRIs are
basically like a big machine if it's
usually a big tube and you go inside and
you hear a bunch of banging around and
magnetic fields produce a detailed image
of a part of your body um typically
especially in clinical settings we're
dealing with structural MRIs they're
just static images in my case the brain
so you would just get a picture of the
brain different structure my research
stone gonna discuss today was more
interested
in the functioning of your brain and
brain activity in that case you need to
use something called functional fmos
functional MRI fMRI which actually is an
image of the brain overlaid with images
of brain activity so fMRI actually
measures changes in blood flow to
different areas of your brain and the
assumption is that blood flow is an
indicator of neuronal activation so a
neuron is a cell in your brain and we
think that one in area or whether like a
clump of those cells is in use or it's
activated blood flow to that area
increases so we produce images like this
and the highlighted areas are where we
do see an increase in blood flow to that
area of the brain and we can say that
area of the brain is activated there are
two major fMRI paradigms or experimental
models that are common these days
the first which i think is more
traditional which if you've heard about
them right before you probably heard of
this it's called task based fMRI and
basically what happens is you go into
the Machine you go into the MRI machine
and you do a task while you're in the
machine and then you don't do the task
you just kind of lie there um and you
contrast images of your brain when
you're doing the task versus images when
you're not doing the task and the change
in activation between those two
conditions indicates the parts of your
brain that were needed to do the task
itself another paradigm is called
resting state of undressing feet
basically you go into the Machine and
you lie there and you daydream and they
just take images of blood flow of the
brain and what we can learn from resting
state and our
is a bit about functional connectivity
so what we think happens is if blood
flow increases to two parts of the brain
simultaneously of a lot of the time we
think that those brains are connected
into a network so the two areas of the
brain that I'm going to talk about today
in terms of the network that we looking
at are the amygdala and the prefrontal
cortex the amygdala is this little blue
area which is like kind of deep and
that's the emotional processing center
of your brain the other area right over
here it's called the prefrontal cortex
the slide actually is more specifically
both at medial prefrontal cortex which
is more accurate but for the purposes of
today we could just call it to be kind
of in the front of their brain and it's
the part of your brain that is in charge
of self-regulation I don't know if any
of you guys have heard of the term
executive functioning but the prefrontal
cortex is responsible for that it's sort
of a control center
so in resting state of our eyes we see
that there's an inverse relationship
between these two regions as the PFC
because more activated the amygdala
becomes less activated so as blood flow
increases two prefrontal cortices blood
flow decreases two amygdala and what we
think is happening here is that they're
involved in an emotion regulation
network or circuit and the prefrontal
torque cortex a sort of shutting off or
regulating the emotions that are
processed in the amygdala all make sense
over
so now I think they can having just
after a knowledge of statistics and at
the right research and neuroanatomy to
understand the study that's I'm gonna
tell you that today as I said before I'm
fellowship I was involved in the promis
project research study which was a big
neuroimaging study of reading disorder
resist part of that study we recruited
43 participants total 22 of them have
reading disorder and 21 did not have
reading disorder and we call them
typically developing peers they were all
children ages 7 to 12 monolingual
monolingual English speakers and in a
word so we wanted to make sure that the
reading disorder group in the typically
developing group were matched for a
number of demographic demographic
variables such as age gender or
handedness race ethnicity and
socioeconomic status and the reason for
matching the groups on those variables
we could stay then more confidently that
if we saw a difference between these
groups whose probably due to the reading
disorder and not one of the other
variables that could gotten in the way
we gave everybody a complete
neuropsychological battery I don't know
if any of you have done the Rose thanks
test and we're doing it without their
own sake testing but basically what that
means if you do bunch of paper and
pencil tasks that are supposed it's has
different skills and those skills each
map to a different part of the brain so
we can see what's the cognitive profile
in which areas of the brain do we think
are implicated and strengths so that
student in which areas of the brain are
implicated in weaknesses
part of the neurons take battery with
testing academic skills especially
reading because it was a study on
reading disorder the test that was the
most relevant to the study that I'm
going to tell you about it's called the
port that's the great oral reading test
and what the kids did was they had a
passage that was on paper and they read
it out loud
we timed them and we marked how many
words they got wrong
out loud and then once they were
dominant for the passage away and they
just seen at answer some comprehension
questions so what the test we measured
did something called oral reading
fluency and reading fluency is sort of a
combination between reading raped and
reading accuracy so we can see if they
were fast and accurate readers they had
good reading fluency if they were slow
and inaccurate readers is that they had
a score of reading fluency we also gave
them questionnaires to assess their
emotional functioning so it was just
right in their emotions and we scored it
all of the kids also did a big MRI scans
and structural and functional and task
based and recipes for this study that
I'm going to tell you about we only used
the resting state data the first thing
that we noticed about the kids that
participated was that there was a real
behavioral connection between anxiety
and reading so based on the neuropsych
scores alone we saw across the full
sample not just reading disorder but
reading disorder and typically
developing kids myth had the most
anxiety had the poorest reading fluency
so those two variables were correlated
um we also noticed that there was a
difference in emotion regulation
circuitry between those two groups
between the reading disorder group and
the typically developing group I do you
think back to a few slides ago what I
told you is that normally what we see is
that as PHP increases amygdala decreases
but when we saw kids with reading
disorder it actually as a Meghna let
increase prefrontal cortex also increase
so rather than a typical inverse
that we expected without a direct
relationship um
and we thought that maybe that meant
that kids with reading disorder had
ineffective regulation of their anxiety
so we wanted to test why do we think
that this is happening so we tried a
mediation model and we took into account
the relative functional connectivity
between the amygdala and prefrontal
cortex the anxiety scores and the
reading fluency force we've got them all
into the model and what we found was
that anxiety in fact mediated the
relationship between the amygdala PFC
connectivity and reading impairment um
so what that told us was ignited in
reading deficit deficits have a shared
biological mechanism so since the
functional connectivity between a
piggelin yet she was associated with
both anxiety and reading we thought that
anxiety was contributing to or even
ambassador meeting is activating the
reading difficulty is that the kids had
and it's really important to note that
this model was true across the entire
sample so this was not a reading
disorder specific issue this was seen
also in typically developing
so now that we know that there is
actually a neurobiological link between
anxiety and reading and I don't know we
didn't test other aspects of learning or
academic skills but I wonder if there's
a similar feedback loop between anxiety
and other areas of study um what do you
guys do um so it seems like reading is a
slow effortful and anxiety provoking
experience even for some kids without
reading disorder because of amygdala PFC
connectivity kind of screwing up those
processes I think that means for all of
you guys that you really do need to
address your symptoms and then anxiety
when you're trying to improve reading or
when you're trying to study in general I
think that there's three major things
that we need to talk about the first is
self-care my fun today that never snack
so bad I think that's great you need to
watch what you're eating you need to
watch your sleep you need to eat break
give yourself some time off exercise do
things you enjoy laughter
I don't know if that means that you're
doing self-care and sleeping you really
just don't I work with high schoolers
who are having trouble in school on I
know that sometimes taking care of
themselves like the bottom of their
priority but they just don't have time
to do it where their parents are putting
so much pressure on them where their
teachers are putting so much pressure on
them to study study study but just
really this massive most effective way
to approach it you do need to take time
for yourself to do things you enjoy to
get yourself a branch
there's a branch of clinical psychology
called cognitive behavioral therapy and
they cognitive behavioral therapist
teach a lot of coping skills some of
them are visualizing being somewhere
relaxing like the beach slide I showed
earlier you can take deep breath you can
tense and then relax your body to chill
out your muscle but there's a lot of
coping strategies that you can learn to
decrease your anxiety when you have a
lot of work to do another thing that I
actually think is the most helpful that
is also really really easy to ignore but
you have a lot going on is to use
effective time management and make sure
that you study over many days because
that sort of space studying and parcel
and repetition really gives you more
exposure to the material to taking you
stressed out and as you become more
exposed and more familiar if your
anxiety will decrease and with that I
always think it's a really good idea
that one attacks taking experience is
really stressful for you to try to mimic
that experience in your studying so it's
going to be a multiple choice test quiz
yourself in a multiple choice format so
again you're exposed to that sort of
experience and when you get there it's
not so stressful and emotionally
arousing
um okay so let's chat any question show
you how the night
[Music]
swag after I looked up what's ours we're
getting in okay this mic is coming which
I didn't
so let's go with the first question over
here
I have a few questions actually it might
personally be what is your motivation
for researching this design the truth
like there's a few things that kind of
my interests were shaped by a few
different things the first is that I
always really liked working with kids
originally if I'm gonna be a
pediatrician and then I got to be a
teacher but I kind of stumbled upon
psychology and I really like the
one-on-one relational experience of
being with people so that's why I became
a psychologist in terms of the learning
staff I was like really blessed to have
enjoyed school for my entire life and I
feel like I'm in a position where I can
help other people also enjoy school it's
like the worst thing in the world I
think to eat school you guys are stuck
there all day every day five days a week
for eight years in your leg like if it's
a drag that's kind of thing so I really
want to help other people realize that
the joy in learning and the relevance to
light and have it not be such an arduous
process so that's why I have been
working with learning disabilities and
studying them as possible another
question
another question is for some
misconceptions people might have about
this oh we were just talking about it
earlier before I heard him talk I sort
of hate to say this but it's something
that I think everybody should know
students in theater of appearances the
field of neuroscience is relatively new
and the brain isn't really really really
complex complex organ there's so much we
don't know
even within justice training field and
fMRI research the methodologies that
were using are constantly getting
revived and we're finding out that
things that we thought were true are in
fact not true at all like I think that
the especially to describe the
experience of being a scientist and that
for me at least the more I learned the
less I think I know so in terms of where
the field is right now to make such a
clear link to education like I know that
neuroscience is really hot in education
right now and we all want to incorporate
neuro scientifically based techniques
into classrooms and everything
I don't know if we're ready to do that
yet to be honest so big misconceptions
is that we know how to take our
knowledge of the brain and to apply it
we don't yet
we're next steps to your research we
still continue on designee or on
learnings of Blair height improve
learnings so my research is actually
taking quite a turn now doing adult
intervention research on people that
have more significant disabilities than
the ones I studied when I was at
Columbia so now I'm saying young adults
who have autism and related disorders
and I'm trying to figure out um what
interventions work best for those sorts
of populations and so I don't think yeah
now I am studying learning but learning
and I get the different level than I was
alright I'm gonna come back here without
bumping into this camera area
hi um I was wondering did you assign
like a specific point value or like how
did you measure your anxiety specific
question um which
there's a bunch of breeding Scouts that
exist in the field of psychology and
what happens is you fill out a
questionnaire all of the questions that
you answered are each scored on as we
set a point value and then all the tests
are normed so let me explain to you what
that means the board must have published
the testing company tried out that test
on thousands of people and they measure
what's the average score are one
thousands and thousands of people take
this test and then what's the
distribution of those scores so we could
figure out what's the average and then
what's the variability and each story's
been assigned a percentile and a
standard score so you can see how
different you are from the average so
that's what happened with the exact
measure so you fill out the score and
then we measure your score against the
norm sample of people your age so if you
are 18 years old we see in the norm
population in this sample that is the
test was tested on how did 18 year olds
respond and where do you fall in
relation to those people thank you
all right heads up full ask another
question I'm gonna you have it what else
all right so okay what exactly happens
when the amygdala and the prefrontal
cortex don't work together it could that
be one of the causes of like learning
disorders that's a really great question
um and I think I would try to do a whole
bunch more research to definitively tell
you the answer to your question but I
can tell you what I think based on my
clinical work and what I've read I don't
know if anxiety causes learning
disorders a lot of people actually think
the river so I think that more people
that I work with think that they're
still anxious because they're not doing
well in school
alternatively people might say you're so
anxious that you're not paying attention
in class so you're not learning as well
you're so focus on your own emotions
that you're not available to learn the
information so maybe one's causing the
other maybe it's the opposite I actually
think that learning difficulties and
anxiety are part of the same disorder so
I think anxiety is actually a crucial
piece of a learning disorder rather than
a causal learning disorder and I think
that this amygdala PFC connectivity
issue is part of a more general
self-regulation issue that is faced by
people with our new quarters so yeah
okay but again I'm not sure like I don't
I don't think anybody else has either
all right I'm coming over here
here you go
[Music]
so during your research I had some
questions how long did your research
last I wasn't fellowship for linear the
study was going on five years before I
got there until going on now so this is
a long ongoing study a lot of that fun
right there to take a lot of time
between it takes a long time to recruit
a sample to get them all tested there is
always funding issues that are in the
mix that we need to deal with it again
studies take a very very long time this
particular paper I started I started
doing the data analysis in the summer of
2016 and the paper was published in the
fall of the parish so another question
is there any like limitations that you
saw while you doing the research that
you wish that the future generation
console yeah the most important one is
it's really hard to stamp in there are a
lot of things that we can do
mathematically to control promotion in
the scanner
if you move it's gonna kind of throw off
the image but so people leave sooner
than I am have kind of figured out
statistical techniques to deal with that
activity so that we could kind of screen
out what's fake and what's at what are
we actually looking at but that needs to
be really refined so if anybody is
really good at neural physics and
statistics and wants to take on how to
better do neural imaging
kids and other populations that are
difficult to study that an area of
research that's wide open I have a
question so in high school you said you
are interested in chemistry and physics
yeah um so how do you make the shift
from that to psychology um they're not
as I'm related and you would think
chemistry is huge in the field of
psychology chemistry public using the
field of psychiatry and
psychopharmacology and medications and
treatment neurotransmitters all that
physics is huge and neural imaging and
scanning techniques so I don't think I
was really so far afield um I know that
sometimes when you're learning the
basics of the field you sort of think
how am I going to possibly use this in
my life but if it's interesting and you
pursue it further or you can see how it
funneled down into a tiny tiny little
part of that deal that you think is
fascinating and you could really delve
into that little tiny corner and I think
that that's kind of what I did
let's see my son Aryan first my question
was more with what used mentioned
earlier in the session and viewers begin
to my statistics and you mentioned how
to determine a mediator if I'm getting
that word correctly between of their
relationship between factors I would
appreciate if you would be able to go
over that one more time sorry I could
like some people are better at efficient
than I am to tell you the truth I wasn't
sure related to specific alleles that
are the best fit for a dataset um I went
into the study with high pop that
giggle xm5 do it
there's two things you can do you better
hypothesis-driven research you could say
I think that this is what's going on and
test it since either right that's what I
did
and I got really lucky that it worked I
actually did think that the enzyme is
the mediator the other thing you could
do is just dump everything in and go on
what people call it fishing expedition
this is not the best way to do it I
think it's kind of dumb things into the
bottle and see if your model works it
doesn't work trying different one um
this is the one that fits best
and I was happy with it because I'm not
sure I would be able to make a
conclusion in about any other sequence
initially what came back I thought was
that the resting state functional
connectivity was the mediator and I was
like I have no clue what that means from
like a practical real-life standpoint um
so this is sort of like thought was
going on in it fit but I wasn't to
figure out
[Music]
Oh
I was in a clinical psychology program I
didn't learn neuroimaging as a graduate
student I learned everything that I
needed to know on fellowship it was huge
I needed to learn about the theory
behind fMRI and then I needed to learn
the computer program that align these
crazy datasets so I knew psychology I
kind of knew from a clinical standpoint
how I thought people learned but in
terms of the logistics and the skills I
needed to develop to test my hypotheses
that was a huge learning curve and
there's still so much I mean I spent two
years like reading manuals and
practicing and trying things out and
they're still so so much I feel like we
barely scratch the surface there's so
much to know okay over here
hi Oh what's what's the brand up to be
able to let you know if they're
claustrophobic in the MRI machine no but
their screams to come out oh yeah my
first real research if I was involved in
a public health study when I was a
graduate student and reproductive health
counseling school-based health clinic
which was fascinating I learned about
pregnancy prevention and what our school
nurse is doing and if hospitals have
clinics in schools what are they doing
and what are the barriers to getting
effective contraception methods to
teenagers but actually my dissertation
for my graduate degree would question
as someone who's a high school student
and found anxiety I was wondering what
your opinion is as a psychologist would
be like for dealing with back I'm gonna
have you to hold your question into the
activity net okay we're gonna do a
little group therapy session and we'll
go over some strategies that you've used
but if anxiety is really a problem in
your life I highly recommend about
peaking mental health care I think
everyone should be in there I think that
everyone has stress in their lives and
we're all sort of handling that stress
as best we can but there's always ways
to do it better and there's no shame in
getting help to figure out those better
ways to handle whatever it is that
you're facing it's all real and we all
need support so if you are really
experiencing issues with mullin or
anxiety or anything else speak up hey I
have a question right here Luke from
studying the children with reading
disorders to young adults with autism do
you see yourself branching off again
you know this interesting part of being
a scientist is it Jack studying whatever
it is that you're interested in you're
also kind of bound to what is the world
interested in and what sort of research
is being funded and where is the world
moving where or the questions they jerk
flip to answer I think that's just the
reality of the field so I was able to
find a position that was funded that I
was able to pursue questions that I was
interested in and I felt confident and
answering and I'm not discovering a
whole new world of studying that I
honestly didn't
if I was on fellowship I actually wasn't
really thinking much about adults that
kind of development with developmental
disabilities but now that I'm worried
about world and I think it's totally
fascinating and it's really rich for
study and there are people that really
need the information in about I was kind
of reading this where you studied was it
just a general one or was it
or a whole bunch of different types you
know so much about reading the burner
I'm stomach rat most people that speak
to you think that reading disorder and
just like we are being fast to the same
thing but you think you know more so to
explain to everybody else um reading
disorders is difficulty reading
you don't read as well as you should
given your age giving our educational
exposure are given the instruction that
was provided to you but it doesn't
explain why it's just a label to
describe people that are not reading as
well as we think they should be dyslexia
is a specific deficit is something
that's called phonological processing
and that's a really specific skill that
means that you can hear a sound and you
could match that sound to a letter you
could make the correspondence between a
sound and the symbol that matches up a
background then you could discriminate
between sounds and you could manipulate
sounds and move them around and say a
word but delete one syllable from that
sound of you from that word so if you
have difficulty manipulating sounds and
matching them to the symbols that
describe them it's going to be very
difficult to read it that's just Lexia
you might also just have a general
language comprehension at you so you
could decoding words you could
physically even read the word itself
just fine but then making meaning of
that word is difficult and you'll have a
reading disorder but you won't have
dyslexia so those are two or you can
both you say have a comprehension issue
in dyslexia um this is a mixed bag so we
had some dyslexic with some nuns like
that so we didn't actually
but good lesson three I'll come down
here because we're sitting in the front
what other topics besides excited would
you be interested in research in the
future I love math I actually when I
went on fellip said I really wanted to
study math the problem with math is that
we don't know anything about it reading
research is way far ahead map reader so
who was the person that asked me well
the third study math is like the Wild
West
so if anybody wants to study
neurobiological processes underlying
math studies shown a correlation between
dopamine levels and the amount of
anxiety someone faces I didn't study
neurotransmitters
good question though okay like people
that do psychiatry research into like
medication trials do more work with
neurotransmitters men just plain old
thermal imager so if you want to
complete to start reading psychiatry
journal hi two things the first thing
when they're going and you found that
there was an inverse relationship
between the conductivity between the PSD
and the amygdala what triggered activity
in each state that's the first the
second one is in year like extra images
saying that the activity would be like
in the amygdala if there was little to
no activity in the PFC
I didn't meet the discovery of the
inverse relationship between can't seem
to make a lot that was there are tons of
other studies that found that before I
even got here um I did replicate that
finding though so I saw that in my like
low anxiety no reading issue part of the
sample they did show the typical pattern
of this inverse connectivity in terms of
what causes that inverse pattern
remember that this is resting seat so
all they were doing is they were lying
in the scanner they weren't doing and it
can be worn doing a particular task so
actually I don't know what caused it is
you kid this just that's just kind of
one your brand left to its own devices
how do these regions interact and that's
what we see um if there were no can't
see
so somebody typically had no frontal
lobe
they have really leader difficulty of
self regulating is many aspects of life
including emotions so they just might be
very emotionally labile so what that
means is that they'd have really high
eyes and really low lows and switch from
one move to another very quickly be
really easily overcome by the room
and if you have in Teaneck samples um I
think we move just a couple more
questions but yeah I wanted to ask um
what we did you would you prefer to stay
in here because of how many people or
something try to go out of there I
didn't think would be cool if everybody
like kind of blend a group that do you
guys think you could do that here like
to speak with the people around you or
[Music]
two more questions
grab someone raise your hands if you
have questions you're asking this
question because Bartlett if you have a
question that I don't have time to
answer today just come find me I'm happy
to give you my email I'm doing a follow
up and she asked me about the now I'm
totally happy to continue the covers
next
so they're doing a ton of one more last
question there you go you got the honors
it might be the discussion of a
confounding variable blundering with
respect to your test subjects we're the
ones with the reading disorder where
they squeak or some sort of like visual
issue like because that could contribute
to problem they were there for our if
any they had an IQ test
they had attentions testings executive
functioning testing testing for
psychopathology so actually it's
important to know that none of the kids
actually had a full-blown intense
anxiety disorder they kind of had what
we called some clinical anxiety so they
had higher than normal level of the
anxiety but I wouldn't say that they had
a diagnosis of a
so we screened out depression we
screened out
peachy we tested we made sure that they
had a recent vision and hearing test so
we tried to deal with as many of those
compounding variables that we could
possibly think of
okay great so before you guys get a
please make sure that you are taking
your garbage with you - Toto the
custodial staff here are our friends and
of you would like to keep it that way
since I love them secondly grab your
stuff and try to find us tea at one of
the circle tables
[Applause]